this was supposed to be the budgets that
would complete George Osborne's
austerity mission instead it was the
budget that ended it the Chancellor has
decided that there's going to be no more
cuts in total state spending things are
going to be better more expensive from
now on he seemed to find something like
27 billion pounds more money but where
from and why did he spare all these
departments all the acts work that they
were expecting let's find out of course
George Osborne wasn't really cutting
spending not in the way that his critics
would have you believe you can see there
his total state spending plans were
going to go down just a little bit
before rising in five years time he
decided that's far too long to wait the
new plan is to increase spending by
about ten billion pounds a year on
average up significantly and up for the
foreseeable future this is why every
newspaper said it was the end of
austerity I mean perhaps not entirely
true there's going to be plenty of cuts
for plenty of departments but overall
the government is going to get more and
more expensive now you can see where the
money from this is coming from through
tax rises this was a tax and spend
budget with eleven point six billion
taking from companies in the form of an
apprenticeship levy and the second
homeowners are being hit for 3.8 billion
but diesel supplements and company cars
isn't going to be abolished it was going
to so various ways of raising taxes to
pay for this splurge now the biggest
winner as you can imagine is the
Department for International Development
so foreign aid up 21% but health is up
3% far more than George Osborne could
otherwise it goes away with even defense
is up two percent for the Foreign Office
it's a wash education one percent not
very much and for the Home Office down
five percent which is funny because the
police budget is being protected or
server Chancellor told us it makes you
wonder where all the rest of the Home
Office cuts are going to come from for
Culture Media and Sport that's only five
percent down it could have been a lot
more and the Arts Council budget is
being protected justise down fifteen
percent no wonder Michael Gove has taken
an interest in non-custodial solutions
to looking after prisoners
energy and climate change down 16
percents perhaps the best single piece
of news in the spending review and
councils are down
29% which is significant because you can
probably expect that bill to be passed
to us via higher council tax down the
road and the transport is the biggest
loser down 37% now let's see what the
government looked like when David
Cameron took office health absolutely
massive 104 billion others 157 billion
but education still 54 billion defense
30 and dipp'd 6 now at the moment very
significantly more being spent on health
education is the same a bit less on
defence and a bit more ornate the pain
has come from the various others as the
home office transport councils the
others we've just seen in five years
time how's it gonna look
119 billion for Health far bigger
education still pretty much a real terms
freeze over 10 years a defense still not
particularly big international aid 10
million way up from 6 billion while most
of the pain has been focused on those
others now tax credits had to be
reformed you can see why the bill for
unemployment benefits was under control
but the bill for tax credits out of
control look at that is dwarfing the
unemployment benefits which is 180 or
jobs per wanted to reform but even he
wasn't going to reform that much his
original plan was to take away you know
a few billion quid in tax credits it
wasn't going to save him as much as it
was going to so politically he might
have wondered why was all that pain
necessary he hasn't exactly abandoned
this plan let's have a look it's the new
proposal you can see he's going to save
pretty much the same but it's by methods
which are less politically controversial
now over the years George Osborne has
basically given up on his original
deficit plan he wanted to have done with
it by now but he's given himself three
more years to balance the books and bits
this has left us
the third biggest deficit in the Western
world it's still one massive big burden
which he somehow has to shift while
doing all of his spending but during
that time he did cut corporation tax he
did cut tax for employees and as a
result he managed to stoke growth let's
look at the rest of em Europe's growth I
mean you can see Spain in Italy there is
appalling and Germany in France not very
good but Britain now has the best
recovery in Europe projected to be even
better in the years ahead and the jobs
miracle I mean even our economic growth
would not have led you to believe that
employment was going to be so big every
time George Osborne stands up to give a
statement he has to revise upwards
his projections for the economy the
economy is creating jobs a far faster
rate than he would have expected and the
best thing of all for him is that wages
are finally going up as well his hope
will be that all of us estera T will be
overshadowed by the fact that the
economy is recovering in a way that will
leave more people more people with far
more money